he opened the book with uh yeah that
quote from Camus it's a strong strong
quote Camu brings me to tears and it's
funny because I reread the Mythic
Sisyphus which I'd been recommending to
people I'm like this book is not good
but he's got his ethos is my favorite of
all the philosophers sounds like the
myth of Sisyphus was a myth
he says after I cute
all I maintain is that on this Earth
there are plagues and there are victims
and it's up to us so far as possible not
to join forces with the plagues and why
I have that as the introductory quotes
the book is
I think morality and ethics are very
very complicated subjects there's lots
of gray areas where you don't know which
way to choose but at a base level he has
another quote that subscribed to him he
never actually said but something about
um you know is the duty of thinking
people not to be in the side of the
executioners
if you are go we should do whatever we
can not to have blood on our hands not
to be murderers not to want death and
that in and of itself is a big pill for
a lot of people to swallow we're all
brought up taught that war is a last
resort and yet when it comes to
International Affairs it's always often
a first priority and people are champing
at the bit to start going in and killing
people and what war means isn't good guy
soldiers versus bad guy soldiers it my
concern is always with the civilians
with the kids who become orphans with
the wives who become widows and and
things like that and then communities
which are you know ruined forever uh so
I I love that quote of his I think he's
I mean the book started it was going to
be a reconceptualization of Camus
thought I was going to rip off my old
buddy Ryan holiday what he did with the
stoics and do about Camus and then when
I started rereading community I'm like
oh there's I've read more into him than
is really there and then he went a whole
other direction uh so you wanted to do
almost
like an existentialist Manifesto so like
imagine one must imagine sis was happy
well more like kamu for today and and
what his philosophy can teach us like
Ryan did with his many books about
stoics yeah
and it was going to be called the point
of Tears
live to the point of Tears yes but the
title was give me the point of Tears no
I know but that from that one that's a
good line right yeah he has so many good
lines yeah maybe it's not about like
shitty in bed though right well no he
was a big he was a big lothario he was
probably he got around
what percent of the audience of humans
on Earth do you think know the the word
letharia what percent of them have a
computer look it up
lothario it's not some weird term sorry
l-o-t-h-a-r-i-o lothario lothario a man
who behaves selfishly in response to
being his sexual relationships with
women they're seduced by handsome in
quotes they're seduced by Handsome
lothario who gains control of their
financial affairs oh I I didn't think I
always thought it was divorce just
someone who's like a stud like a player
but not a player yeah there's a I'm 11
malevolent oh I didn't realize that okay
well then selfishly okay that's not him
irresponsibly in a Man Too
um
although Ein Rand would be proud
selfishly well nothing's wrong with
selfish she wouldn't like that kind of
selfishness that's actually behaves a
man who behaves selfishly and irresp
irresponsibly in his sexual
relationships with women
huh
yeah okay so he was he was just a player
uh not a maybe it's maybe a stud I don't
think he was promiscuous particularly
Nietzsche didn't get he got he didn't
never got laid right
the pro it was from prostitutes was it
okay possibly yeah you're asking me like
I knew the guy I I heard it's from
um it he never had a deep loving
fulfilling relationship he had a very
skewed understanding on uh the way he
wrote about women although somebody
wrote to me and said that's a
mischaracterization that he was actually
very respectful yeah but he had that
line if you're going before women bring
a whip wasn't that him was that show but
if I were to quote you from your Twitter
yeah I think I could make a very
convincing argument that you're sexist
racist and probably a Nazi
well I do own like
some of Hitler's stuff exactly I I got
the I rest my case I feel like I'm a
Nuremberg
it's a noose
you should have thought about that when
you were saying all those things